[Music]
that's my birthday yeah thank you very
much number 18
yeah april 12 12
april 12th uh you have the same birthday
as my cats it's april 12th
i don't know your birthday and i don't
know your birthday what are you august
12
12 august 12th what's yours i'm a gemini
i guess
i don't know what that mean oh it's just
your birthday huh oh you're happy
birthday 10 days ago
he's like no i was like oh yeah
ninth day birthday man thank you i'm in
june june 4th june 4th
november 29th okay so this story
is all about birthday patterns right so
this subreddit called data is because
birthdays mine's on the same day every
year
so this subreddit called data is
beautiful they
like someone in that's already got this
this
graph like they created this graph with
the information that's being provided by
the
the social security administration of
the united states where they got
from the years 2000 to 2014
they they charted everyone's birth
somebody
so it says the most common birthdays in
the united states from 2000 to 2014.
wow as you can see here so blue is
relatively more common so
if your birthday lands on a blue day
it's more common
orange is relatively less common and
then uh this
gray ish is more average [ __ ] at
in the beginning of the year so that's
the thing so they're saying that
with this chart here you could kind of
see that like humans have
a mating season actually and they have
an ability to hold their babies in
on holidays no look no one's being born
on a holiday like okay
it's it's it is like that but not really
it's not holding them in it's because
there's like inducing
that gets scheduled okay there are
c-sections that are no no no christmas
yeah so and then also people were
looking into it and they were like
oh because right here it says december
25th is the least common birthday
followed by january 1st
july 4th wow 24th and july 4th wow
because everyone will get outshined by
jesus so they're not trying to have a
same birthday
so here's the thing god's like you don't
share the same birthday as jesus theory
a theory is that because
doctors and hospital staff they don't
want to be working necessarily during
the
nobody did right so then they they end
up scheduling patients
to be induced to have c-sections around
the holidays
you better maybe that's why that makes
sense less
let me ask you is that the 25th yeah
that's what i thought yeah this is the
25th and then right here
is the first january 1st and plus when
santa's working hard
nobody's going to have babies that night
no christmas you're also like
because those times are of high stress
and you're not thinking about it because
like your stress could also add to when
you give birth
like especially around that time mama
gotta say happy new year yeah maybe i
don't know how it really works but like
maybe you're just like trying to like i
had a baby i don't know how it works
happy new year
look how common september is so that
means they weren't having babies but
they were [ __ ] in christmas
that's exactly what it kind of concludes
which like i said that
humans seem to have a mating season
that's chris kringle he visits everybody
that seems to be chris king can't
wrangle his [ __ ] i feel he's like
genghis khan
when you're quarantined in the how in
christmas
or winter time there's nothing to do but
to [ __ ]
so you'd start [ __ ] damn imagine how
many births are gonna happen this year
during christmas if we're still in corn
oh actually there's a lot of
a lot i forgot the number but there's
like thousands of women six trillion
thousands of women um are they have lost
their birth control
because of changes in governments and
all these things
effects of the pandemic i have really
poor information in my brain right now
baby boom but that's what they're saying
that they're predicting a pandemic baby
boom because of that
it's a bamboo wow and they're going to
be immune to coronavirus
you know what's crazy so there's like
seven or eight billion people alive
right now
right yeah it's almost eight yeah almost
eight so say like in a hundred years
we're gonna have to bury all these
people
wow that's eight billion people for like
150 years because people being worn out
well
they're creating different technologies
to to
every 100 years there's eight billion
people that are going to be dead
well they don't all even die at the same
time of course not
in one city dude and also the the
different like the
human life the history of humans
humans they haven't really had this many
people be alive at one time
as far as i remember reading like we
currently have
the most amount of people yeah in the
1950s there was still only like two
billion people
on on this planet so in the 1950s to now
it's like
ballooned to 8 billion yeah i shouldn't
say human history because
as far as they have been keeping records
but in terms of like say like
people that want to get married there's
already like a lot of the land that
they're like yo
we can't bury you there's like a cremate
yeah so i'm saying but like there's a
lot of people that don't want to create
well that's what makes me wonder like
when you buy a plot
and like you really own like your body
is the only thing in that plot of land
for
all of eternity nah they're gonna forget
dig up
it's supposed to be so my my grandpa is
buried at rose hills over here
um so is easy oh cool yeah he is and my
dad
and his brother are already bought plots
of land next to them
so the whole family could be together
and it's kind of like real estate where
you buy you're buying that little that
piece of land and people also buy and
sell
land as if it's real estate too wait
like with people in it or
empty uh empty plots how much is a plot
standard
price i think when my but my dad bought
it so the price also goes up like real
estate really
and is la prices more like more
expensive than like texas real estate
for
grace so for my dad i think he spent
like he bought it in the maybe 90s or
early 2000s and it was 10 g's
for that spot and it could be worth 20
g's now or whatever
i'd rather just get cremated like or why
is it illegal to be like
i'm gonna die can someone bury me in the
forest oh yeah
probably there are laws like that like
you're allowed to sprinkle or you're
allowed to do a sprinkle but just bury
my whole body
i don't want anyone to spend money dump
my body in the ocean yeah like i'm dead
like
yeah but then like what if the national
forest was like
don't be littering no i'm i'm
fertilizing the soil
like what like you're gonna have to let
everybody know about that area because
if somebody like stumbles across
across your body they're going to turn
into like some homicide like the suicide
4 is in japan
that's illegal though yeah that is
illegal killing yourself is illegal
yeah yeah oh yeah but dumping yourself
in the forest is illegal too
what about like shooting like people
into space or something you know that's
a good idea i did that like five years
before i died but they're in a litter
space yeah but littering with your body
is a little bit different than putting i
don't know like a
astronaut in a tesla car and shooting it
what if it mummifies because
you're gonna freeze it doesn't decompose
oh that'd be a scary space travel
imagine all the aliens are invading
earth like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] dead bodies everywhere
that's a protective barrier you know
yeah it'll be space debris
yeah space debris we already have enough
with all these old satellites and [ __ ]
space trash
yeah there's a lot of one we're not even
allowed to bury everyone has to get
cremated because there's not enough
space
yeah hong kong too right in hong kong
they stopped bearing i don't know but
a lot of people cream me in hong kong
for sure yeah you think like
since like it's like really [ __ ] up to
like dig old bodies up out of ground
instead of digging we'll just put more
dirt over everything and put more dead
bodies on top of it yeah oh in the
future oh maybe that's why there's so
many layers and the dinosaurs are way
like they're cause when they buried each
other yeah because there was a real
estate problem with the dinosaurs back
then
they're like this year there was a lot
of deaths with the stegosauruses man
somewhere in the 1900s they're going to
bloom up 8 billion
no because have you seen those old
photos of
cities like for example in la in the
1920s or whatever
you can see what it looked like and then
you see what it looks like now and then
like the street level
back then was significantly lower than
what it is today because we've piled
down so much [ __ ] over the years
isn't that crazy that makes sense like
um what was what was the movie was it uh
blade runner
sure 24 now well anyways point is the
drama
the concept of like the future of even
like los angeles like there's nowhere
else to go sideways so you just have to
keep building up like taiwan or hong
kong or anything like that right
so conceptually in like you know digital
space art and whatever the future
everything goes higher higher higher so
eventually maybe like 50
100 years from now what we consider a
street like you know
uh beverly hills or hollywood sunset
it's actually going to be down here
where buildings are going to be like all
the way up here like the jetsons
yeah and there's going to be like levels
of freeways you know that one famous
part where everyone takes photos in l.a
no we could like look down and like
there's the light but it's the street
no oh yeah next to the hotel right no
look to uh
the walt disney hall oh i think i know
yeah it's the it's the street and then
there's like a overpass but the light
shines through yeah yeah the white light
oh that one no that's the one
where we did the photo shoot for barbara
yes that one um
but that's like underground and when
you're under there it seems like a
normal street and everything
and like you see the outside and stuff
but then they build up yeah i feel like
that's how like you're explaining that's
like just gonna start building the
streets higher and higher and then we'll
just go up but it'll be like futurama
when they go down and it's like the
original city yeah that's what i'm
thinking
and the more you know probably
less rich people really do you think
that that would affect
like if all of society like ends up
doing that
and then we get closer and closer to
space like do you think that's what like
is affecting nah i just
i just debunked myself like you build a
building as tall as atmosphere no no i'm
just thinking i'm like would that affect
like climate and like the way everything
works but i'm like it's not like we're
building up
in nature either so i'm like never mind
that doesn't make sense it depends of
how much people fart out their windows
if you have a whole tower or people just
farting the whole always on layers
filled with farts
it's like the what movie is it elita you
guys see
yeah i didn't i tried conceptually right
like the higher
up you go the higher class you are right
and like everybody out there like their
trash
and their junk that they spit out can be
like treasure to people down here
so to speak oh i want treasure
you know it's crazy we started this
talking about
being born but then most of this
conversation was about
when we die we're more obsessed about
death the
topic of death and about birth well i
think we already figured out that people
[ __ ] in the summer that's why
that's why i was like well anyway or
like [ __ ] i've already been born
haven't died yet gotta figure that one
out true true
i just want a tree house man [ __ ] all
that that's tall enough for me
you guys looking at towers like damn i
don't know
i think a tree house is pretty
sufficient oh yeah cliffhouse you guys
see those cliff houses where i build
like a modern ass house
yeah in the middle of a cliff and i'm
like who built this
tony stark wait isn't that that's a sick
house
yeah that is a really sick house it's
crazy and then i'm like this is so much
a
cliff and uh there's no there's no
costco nearby like where do you get your
groceries this is so much cliff yeah
you gotta climb up or do you feel like
we'll start like building outwards
towards like the ocean since we're on
the west coast over there we're already
maxed out on the ocean you know i mean
like you ever see those little uh
almost i was about to say home pod apple
anyways
um those little pods or like almost like
mini bunkers that float
and then they they turn them into luxury
little kind of
yeah it's like it's literally a circle
uh like the one yeah you go up to them
there's like
bedrooms inside yeah over water bungalow
type stuff but like it floats it doesn't
like
uh stand on like sticks or anything like
that but i i could totally imagine like
a water world kind of city being built
outwards towards the ocean
it would work because of how crazy the
ocean
is like with like the weather and stuff
like there's oh is it just a drift
it's just a floating home imagine if
they're all connected by like nets like
a whole city
you know what i'm saying or like a
man-made island like in dubai
like the palm didn't feel the world no
they just failed with selling them
there's a bunch of houses that they
haven't or they didn't finish
i think but they have like the one
that's the world and the one that's like
the palm trees
yeah the palm trees but there's
properties on them they just don't sell
so they just gotta lower the price i
don't know why no people aren't just
moving there that's crazy
i'd rude there bali is pretty cheap
bollywood
[Music]
[Music]